Elon Musk this cannot be overstated he
in some respects is saving Western
Society right now I don't think this was
his intention when he bought Twitter I
think it might have been sort of in a in
a Kind of Blue Sky way uh but by
allowing people to get information
directly and allowing people to see the
horrors and then also expose the bad
guys who are all too willing to expose
themselves uh we would not have that if
Elon Musk did not have Twitter right we
know that the censorship and the Banning
and all of those things you would they
would be banning and suspending the good
guys and promoting the bad guys but some
of the bad guys are still on there and
it's an interesting philosophic debate
on as to what Elon should do about these
things but I think it is good to know uh
what some of the genuinely bad guys are
saying here is Iranian supreme leader
ali caini uh that video that he linked
to before I read the Tweet is from the
uh the desert the party where 250
Israeli kids I mean you know teenagers
and and 20 something year olds were
killed who were just going to a a
concert he wrote God Willing the cancer
of the usurper Zionist regime will be
eradicated at the hands of the
Palestinian people and the resistance
forces through the region now look
there's you can have a debate like is
that a direct threat to Israel should he
be allowed to be on these platforms
again I sort of think exposing these
things is the best I want to throw you
to a map you know we've shown you a map
a couple different maps of the Middle
East I saw this one this morning Ben
Shapiro tweeted this one out just again
showing you the scale of what we are
talking about we are talking about a
tiny country that red box you're looking
at there the box is probably four times
the size of what Israel actually is it's
the little speck in the box but you
can't even make a box small enough uh
but only if that country was a little
bit smaller we would had have peace that
that seems to be the argument and I
think most people realize it isn't but
Cain is not the only one uh
internationally saying crazy things uh
this is a a tweet from turkey's Deputy
minister of National Education uh he
said one day they will shoot you too you
will die uh that seems like a direct
threat to BB
Netanyahu